KELLY STEWART: Dian Fossey
was definitely a pioneer.
I do not think that
word has been overused.
Before that, nobody had done
a long-term study of gorillas.
Nobody had studied
them month after month
and year after year.
IAN REDMOND: She wanted to
be the scientist who began
the first long-term field
study of gorilla behavior
in their society, and to take
that as far as it would go.
NARRATOR: (READING
FOSSEY'S JOURNAL)
I've been following
one guerrilla group
round all month, and
I'm now able to get
within 30 to 60 feet of them.
To be perfectly frank,
I think they're quite
confused as to my species.
IAN REDMOND: In
order to study them
and learn about
the behavior, Dian
had to get them used to her.
And that process is called
habituation, winning the trust.
The habituation
process is not nice,
because you're upsetting
this family of gorillas
day after day after day.
Dian's methods played on
the gorillas' curiosity.
So she would behave in ways
that would elicit a curious
rather than anger response.
Like when she was climbing
a tree to get a better look,
she would deliberately
ham it up.
And she found that that
got their attention.
NARRATOR: (READING FOSSEY'S
JOURNAL) I've gotten
them accustomed to
me by aping them,
and they are fascinated
by my facial grimaces
and other actions that I
wouldn't be caught dead
doing in front of anyone.
I feel like a complete
fool, but this technique
seems to be working.